if you want to be vc you know it's not
about finance you're not sitting with
excel and calculating how much you know
the p l will work or not
you're trying to figure out you know who
is the entrepreneur especially when it's
early stage investments like you're
working with people so the product is
not really important back then it's to
see if the entrepreneur itself is a good
captain for the ship and if he can take
you
from
a to b
and if you're trusting him
you know when you're going on the sea
you don't know what's what's the weather
or you know the big waves are not big
waves or what will happen so the most
important thing if you believe him that
he is the guy
who will be able to take this ship from
a to b
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders and hello
shy michelle general partner of merlin
ventures and managing partner of two day
ventures chai is a serial entrepreneur
who has founded four companies in the
cbn and it world and for the last five
years has been the managing partner of
two day ventures an israeli seed stage
fund in december of 2020 he joined
maryland ventures to stand up and run
its efforts in tel aviv
shia michelle welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
thank you very much i'm great how are
you i'm doing great thank you so much
for joining me today there's wait for
way too much for us to talk about all
the way from your upbringing to cyber
security to investments to the israeli
ecosystem i'm excited to just dive deep
and get to know you better over these 20
minutes so let's get started chai walk
me through a little bit about your
background and i want to go all the way
back to turkey share with me a little
bit about you know how how big of a part
does turkey play for you besides for the
fact that you speak turkish but what
what is it you know with you and turkey
and how does it play into your work
today
so i grew up in israel i born in israel
but in 1990 my family
just
decided to you know
to make a relocation and to go to turkey
so
seven and a half years old
moving to turkey
and as you can understand
i didn't know any turkish
or anything close to that
uh so that's that's the start like uh
you know i remember was landing to
turkey and that was the first time i saw
ice and and snow
that was amazing and the smell of you
know the smell of the burning
wood of the heaters at houses so that's
my first memory you know from turkey
uh i don't know how much you know turkey
but
you know
not nearly enough except for the fact
that i that i might go there to do a
hair transplant sometime this next year
by the way i know cesaro
anyone that you know just you know ping
min i will try to help you with that
um
so uh
turkey you know for someone from coming
to israel back in the 90s to turkey is
like going back 50 years
going back there and uh you know it's a
different
type of culture is moving to an old
culture a muslim culture where the
discipline is foremost you know the most
important thing
and the people
are very different from what i used to
in israel
so
it's 180 degrees different from you know
what i used to here in israel
and uh and that's how we started you
know that's that's a big change it's not
from moving to tel aviv to to new york
or another country you know where the
culture is maybe
maybe similar but uh it's a huge age to
move to amazon country
uh but you know today when i'm looking
back uh i think that it was good because
you know i got some things that you know
some cultural things you know that i
couldn't get here in israel like
discipline you know the
the protocols
to learn of human behavior like
turkish people are you know
are giving for human life and you know
human behavior a very big respect
so disrespect is something that i missed
here in israel
but you know that's something good that
i got from there so you can choose to
look to the bad things but we choose to
look mostly to the good things that we
got there you know a good childhood a
bit different
but i think that's what made me today
i love it and you know honestly i i
don't know many people that that
relocated to turkey and and obviously
you speak fluent turkish
today and and so it's i'm sure that it's
an interesting you know a journey to to
constantly be looking at these two
cultures and being this you know global
global kid growing up and having those
two tell me a little bit about you know
what you do today but but more
importantly than today you know you've
invested in some incredible companies
you're deep into the into the israeli
ecosystem here into the cyber ecosystem
tell me a little bit about you know the
your career pathway and and what were
some of the big milestones along the way
that really led you to your conviction
of how you told me right before we got
started that you just you simply love
what you do
so you know
uh
maybe it starts when i came back to
israel back then november 2003
i decided to come back to israel
i was studying finance in turkey
i came it was important to make an army
like when you are living in the gola you
know outside of israel uh then as an
israeli one of the things that you want
to do is is to do army
so uh i came to israel to make my army
my service after i made a service i
thought that i will come back
and then i i fell in love with israel
the culture and the army the people that
i met there
and i i decided to stay
and you know in the if you want to stay
as high albuded
uh you need to be both dead after it too
so uh i decided to stay here and uh and
i started to work in lao
uh so i started you know to fly over the
world i think that this was one of my
best
best decision you know people was
laughing in the beginning are you a
flight attendant that's what you do but
i think that that was my best decision
ever because you know incredible in
these years you are flying all over the
world learning lots of cultures
and and back when i flew there and i saw
the people you know in the airplane and
talking to people i understand that i
love to work with people and to help
and uh like i said i want to work in
something that i will help the people
and then you know while working i
started study i met my first partner
there danielle where we started together
uh playground
and uh
and years after you know
working with startups doing startup by
myself
uh i got the opportunity to work with my
partner ronnie
at team code where we started to work
with cyber security companies back then
in 2013 and you know that was when it
all started
uh we met
cyberism in their early stages looming
at in their early stages you know those
are the legacy companies who made the
israeli startup scene and uh and we knew
the entrepreneurs and and then you know
i met some great pcs where they said
if you were investing you know a 50k you
need startup that you work with probably
will be one of the best vcs in israel
and that's how the vc idea came to life
and and then you know
we started today and today we're doing
maryland uh in israel
so i never planned to do to be vc or i
never learned to be investor that's
where life brought me
i i love it can you take me back to this
transition
from flight attendant into the high-tech
ecosystem how does that work
so flight attendant wasn't uh work for
me like it was more a hobby you know and
a a way to make money and travel the
world i knew that i wanted a different
thing
and uh and while i studied i studied
while i was flying so uh
you know i learned and i tried to do the
best so while we were learning and
making the startup i understand it i
love you know the technology back then
you know i'm talking about 2005
where we started you know to think about
what is the next big thing
back then there was ebay so we started
on selling you know stuff on ebay and
then we were first traded yeah we first
because we didn't understand
how to sell on ebay but it wasn't so
easy back then
uh selling on ebay
so
we started there and then we started to
become smarter
we started to say where we are selling
let's find out what are the best sellers
and uh and we started to create
playground and that's how i fell in love
with tech
and i learned the cloud you know back
then it wasn't cloud
but it was cdn world and that's how i
fell in love on you know cloud i learned
a lot about akamai we all bright cove
in 2009 we founded uh sparkio it's
another startup uh where we tried to
bring education online
from cdns
for five years together with my partner
frederick
so you know
you're not getting in love with startups
i think that that's life with where it
brings you in the end
i think you know i i just
i just went with life and that's where
it brings me
now what did you learn about yourself
either you know during the flight
attendant in turkey you know in the city
and iit space than in the cyber security
space so what do you learn about shy you
know throughout those different
experiences whether it's you as a
professional as a thinker as a leader
so first of all i learned that
i'm determined when i want something
so each time i saw someone successful i
i was asking myself what he's doing and
you know how i can be there
and
i think that one of the things that you
know are
part of my you know beliefs is
luck is is difficult to to control so i
prefer to pave my own path with
determination so
that that's i think that's that's the
life that's what i understand about
myself that you know i i like to control
what i do
and you know not leaving it to
something else so that's what i learned
about myself you know that i can do
anything you know if i just want and if
you work really hard and determination
right now as you're entering
you know the vc space
from entrepreneurship and and and
different
industries that that are that are not
you know in the high-tech scene what
what do you experience you know a lot of
people come into the vc space you know
either because they're they're really
into the financial part of it or they're
they're really into you know just being
their part of growing a bunch of
different companies what what was it
that really got you excited you know
being an investor of these companies
so
if you want to work in vc you need to
love people
like you know it's all about people it's
all about you know
helping and you know understand you know
what their needs
so you know i think it's it's a bit
it's not the new news that there is lots
of money out there
so and i think that mostly people
working with people so
if you want to be vc you know it's not
about finance you're not sitting with
excel and calculating how much you know
the p l will work or not
you're trying to figure out you know who
is the entrepreneur especially when it's
early stage investments like you're
working with people so the product is
not really important back then it's to
see if the entrepreneur itself is a good
captain for the ship and if it can take
you
from
a to b
and if you're trusting him
you know
when you're going on the sea you don't
know what's what's the weather or you
know the big waves are not big waves so
what will happen so the most important
thing if you believe him that he is the
guy
who will be able to take this ship from
a to b
and and you do it by by loving people by
trusting them and by learning them so i
think that the most important thing if
you want to bc is to love people
and you know to want to help them
in the right way right now
let's move more to the cyber scene i i'd
love for you to tell me a little bit
about you know cyber security from your
from your lenses
uh you know not coming there from
necessarily the the military background
or or that sort of thing from from a
different perspective and then a little
bit about what you're doing with
maryland today so 2013 you know we are
starting to know to learn more about the
cyber security space
most of the startups name back then was
cyber something
and uh
but but something else happened there
it's the cloud
and you know while the cloud evolved and
you know the cloud becomes something
affordable
i remind you you know back at
2008 if you want to buy
you know terabyte on the cloud it was
costing lots of money
you know with the big change in the
cloud and you know the the affordable
prices of the cloud
technology companies and all the
companies become software oriented so
when enterprises made a switch from
buying technologies to starting to
produce their own technologies
and you think become very popular cyber
security you know today when you're
walking to a flower shop
or you just want to buy a wine you're
not walking to a walk to a shop or store
you're just clicking right
the domain going to the website and
buying the wine
so
that means that this company or using
outsourced company to develop their
technology their software
or those companies like gatexc
flower.com
and other companies that wear groceries
online today are software-based
companies it's not the grocery you know
that we used to have when we're a child
so
having say that we understand that
having said that we understand that
every company today isn't a software
company and when every company's
software you need to secure your systems
so today
in 2000
everything is about cyber and i think
that we're just starting you know
everyone told that it will end by now
but i think that you know
everything is starting now it's the
beginning it's an error of cyber
i i love it and you know obviously
there's a lot of conversation happening
around cyber a lot of words being thrown
around like bubble and some sort
but but i couldn't agree more and i
think that we're just getting started
and as the world becomes becoming more
and more digitalized and what
we've been seeing in the last year and a
half or even two years with with the
pandemic and and and the world literally
digitalizing itself at an exponential
rate cyber security is going to play
just a bigger a bigger part than we
could have ever imagined and a much more
accelerated piece tell me a little bit
about merlin
so i met marilyn nearly four years ago i
met david you know in a nice hotel in uh
in rochester in the cafe talking about
what we are thinking about cyber
security and and just what i told you
about the new era and the totes and um
and david founded merlin
david phelps
25 years ago
where he understand that you know in the
end everyone will be software based and
everyone will need you know to secure
their systems so he founded merlin cyber
and since then it's a huge company in
the u.s you know
today they're selling netskope and other
huge companies uh in a multi-million
dollar uh
you know deals uh
you know they just publish a new deal
that they did for hundreds of million
dollars so knowing this big company you
know and david uh and he invested in
today in our first vc and second vc back
then as a lp
and then we said why we're not doing it
together
or we're not creating you know a vc just
for cyber security israeli-based as i
like you know it's important the money
will come to israel and investing here
in israel
and uh and also we are the cyber nation
you know not just the startup startup
nation so
um and and and we started to do maryland
and uh that's where we decided to get a
which set said spurgle to
to you know to create adventures in
television
incredible incredible and and so shaw i
want to use the last couple minutes just
to dig a little bit deeper about you
know your background and your
personality and i want you to take me
back to your childhood
really what what fascinated you as a kid
what what really sparked your curiosity
whoa my mom used to say that i'm asking
too much questions like i think that's
i think that everything is about you
know i wanted to learn everything
i was even my wife today saying you're
asking lots of questions like
i really want to know everything
uh and and what fascinated me you know
as you remember like growing up in
turkey uh
it's interesting you know i had this
conversation with our team here in tel
aviv
is they're asking how is growing in
turkey so you know it's very interesting
like while the kids here in israel did
some great things you know in turkey
things were different so
the childhood was you know
uh interesting let's say being a jewish
you know
together with 3 000 muslims in the
university uh was challenging or you
know being in the class the only jewish
so
i think that that connected me more to
the israel and that was the reason also
i wanted to come to the army
and and i think that that's also the
reason that you know that i do what i do
today like everything is the wood the
love to the country so childhood
fascinating things are you know i always
wanted to understand the world have
lives and i think that i have some
romantic view about life
um i fell in love with lots of things
you know about you know from nature and
stuff like this so i really like to
travel and see the world
and
and yeah and i think that
that's
that's the point of my childhood like
you know growing up in a museum country
just raised the need
you know for the israeli love and to
travel you know in turkey we couldn't
travel so much
and if there were a few if there's a few
words that
anyone would use to describe shai or
that you would use to describe yourself
what would those be
uh warm-hearted motivated dirty mind
i think those are the things that you
know probably describe you mostly
i love me as a person
shy
thank you very very much this was a
great great pleasure and i really
enjoyed it thank you for sharing this
time with me and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you very much
thank you for having me and thank
you bye